[Musique]
et c'est avec julie chouteau bonsoir
j'ai uniquement soir série alors nous en
a parlé sur france 24 la tension monte
entre israéliens et palestiniens depuis
deux semaines de nouveaux heurts
aujourd'hui et dans ce contexte de
violence des fêtes news fleurissent sur
des réseaux sociaux oui alors
régulièrement à les deux camps
s'accusent mutuellement de
désinformation et depuis plusieurs jours
on voit par exemple circuler ce genre de
tweets vous allez le voir il montre en
fait des images où l'on voit un enfant
allongé au sol la jambe tordu avec du
sang qui semble lui coulait de la tête
et on voit que cette scène est filmée
par une équipe de tournage qui ne
ressemble pas du tout à des journalistes
avant loyers c'est pas du tout du
matériel de journalistes ça ressemble
plus à du matériel de cinéma du matériel
de fiction et pour ses comptes pro
israéliens c'est clair ça en est la
preuve il s'agit de palestiniens en
train de faire une mise en scène pour
faire croire qu'un enfant palestinien a
été blessé par des israéliens avec pour
but quelque part d'attirer la la pitié
en du grand public autour de leur cause
alors ce genre de publication elle est
vraiment devenue virale sur les réseaux
sociaux regarder juste via ce tweet les
images ont été vues 54 mille fois ou
encore vous allez le voir ici dans un
tweet qui a été supprimé mais on a pris
la peine de l'archivé avant qu'ils
soient
qu'ils soient pardon effacé presque 80
milles vu un pour cette vidéo est est ce
que ce qu'affirment ses internautes pro
israélien est vrai est ce que les
palestiniens ont mis en scène de fausses
images d'un enfant blessé alors déjà un
élément est troublant en fait dans cette
vidéo si vous regardez on voit que c'est
une vidéo qui provient de tik tok sauf
que les pro israéliens qu'ils ont
partagés ont barré d'un trait bleu le
nom de la personne qui l'a publié à
l'origine mais tout de même si on zoome
on arrive à voir à lire le prénom
mohammad et le chiffre 9 138 et ses
indices elles permettent ils permettent
de retrouver la vidéo d'origine sur tik
tok la voici et donc on voit bien que la
vidéo est la même sauf que la légende en
arabe elle dit je cite dans les
coulisses du tournage de la scène de
l'agression des colons contre ahmed
ahmed manas sera l'internaute qui a
publié donc cette vidéo à l'origine fait
donc référence un film un et nous avons
aussi un indice supplémentaire le nom
ahmed manas sera on va donc juste taper
les mots clés manas sera est filmé dans
un moteur de recherche est là qu est ce
qu ont trouvé bien on trouve à une bande
annonce d'un film qui s'appelle mti
place et si on va une minute 15 bing on
retrouve bien les images qui circulent
sur internet le même enfant le même
vêtement la même position et vous voyez
la prise de vue de la caméra correspond
à en plus propre en qualité cinéma donc
il s'agit bien des images qui ont
circulé donc ces images sont bien une
mise en scène mais jusque là tout est
normal parce que c'est du cinéma et oui
un décompte israélien dénonce une
tentative de désinformation parce qu'en
fait on est meilleur mais en fait n'est
pas vrai parce qu'on n'a pas retrouvé de
comptes de palestiniens qui prétendent
que la scène est réelle en fait en
personne ne cherche à faire passer ces
images pour des images d'actualité qui
aurait été tournée sur le terrain dans
toutes les publications que nous avons
vues elles sont simplement présenté vers
comme les coulisses d'un tournage de
cinéma d'ailleurs le réalisateur
lui-même un nous a confirmé que ces
images diffusées pour faire croire à
l'effet que nous palestiniennes ont bien
été prises pendant le tournage de son
court métrage c'était ce mois ci donc
c'est un court métrage du cinéma mais ce
que l'histoire est inspirée d'une
histoire vraie ce que le film est
inspiré d'une histoire vraie et oui un
celle d'ahmed namana sera donc un jeune
palestinien condamné à 12 ans de prison
une peine qui a été descendu à 9 ans la
raison il a été reconnu coupable de
l'agression de deux jeunes juifs au
couteau c'était le 12 octobre 2015 ahmed
manas sera était âgée de 13 ans au
moment des faits en fait l'adolescent a
été percuté par une voiture alors qu'il
cherchait à fuir la police
israélienne une vidéo qui montre est
donc cet enfant gisant au sol avaient
d'ailleurs été diffusé sur les réseaux
sociaux il avait été même reprise par
plusieurs médias vous le voyez là il
s'agit de la chaîne américaine
si bies la scène de ce court métrage
donc m type l'oeil c'était donc une
reconstitution de cette vidéo mais qui
n'a jamais été présentée comme autre
chose qu'une reconstitution comme une
fiction extraire des images de films
pour les faire passer pour de la
propagande
le procédé n'est pas inédit et non on
l'avait notamment observer plusieurs
fois déjà depuis le début du conflit en
ukraine par exemple fin février de
nombreux était un vote dénoncé une mise
en scène de la part de médias
occidentaux selon eux qui voulaient
faire croire à de fondre faux
bombardements russes là encore un des
comptes facebook du monde entier
partager des images on voit une équipe
diriger des acteurs qui simule la
panique sauf que là encore avec une
simple recherche d'image inversé on se
rend compte qu'il s'agit tout simplement
d'un tournage de cinéma d'un extrait de
science-fiction anneaux dit le
réalisateur de ce film intime vinci sont
qui en plus a été tournée à birmingham
en angleterre alors vous voyez rien à
voir avec le conflit en ukraine et
c'était la chronique info intox avec
julie chouteau merci beaucoup je dis et
c'est la fin de cette édition merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve dans
quelques minutes à tout de suite
[Musique]